you know we just showed this clip from
Avengers age of Ultron and that was shot
in London your stomping grounds yes is
it good to be back in London is when you
go back there do you feel like ah does
your skin breathe differently are you
happy you're in London it was really
great you know I left I left London at
the beginning of the at the end of the
90s and it was kind of dying and it
really felt like a vibrant 90s went nuts
yeah London and it really felt like a
vibrant town again it was great however
the most humiliating thing that has ever
happened to me happened just before we
started started shooting when you first
arrived in London to shoot yeah age of
Ultron what happened well um I have to
suppose it very badly time set what I
want to say that was I've seen some
badly time sips in my day it's it's a
that was just terrible it was vodka and
it's it's I'm about to tell you the most
humiliating thing there right so you're
preparing yourself we didn't the fights
yeah yeah yeah so there was a there was
a there was a there was a party at
dinner party at Guy Ritchie's house you
know I read a really great director get
great director and his wife was there
Ron Howard was there you know dear
friend of mine his wife was there I keep
Goldsman who wrote beautiful mine was
there
Lizzie Olsen was there Chris Evans with
it was just a star-studded evening when
I I get very nervous at these things so
I know you're not a party guy you don't
like to go out knowing Dean by I don't
do any of it and and so I had elected I
you know I'm I play the vision what's
ironic is I'm kind of myopic right I
can't see a thing so I decided bearing
in mind it was Guy Ritchie's party to
not wear my glasses and look young and
frankly castable right sorry sure you
meeting with a big director I make sense
they don't wear the glasses very
important to preface this story with I
am now not wearing glasses yeah and
we're in his palatial mansion in the
middle of London and we're sitting down
he's making small talk and he says you
know I have a pool downstairs and I have
you you have a swimming pool in a London
Tower
yeah yeah I have one in the basement you
should go check it out now but right
behind me at the dinner tables here
right behind me as an elevator okay so I
go into the elevator and I press the
basement floor and I go down the doors
open and I'm expecting to hear like kids
playing in the pool with nannies or
whatever sure and it's just pitch black
so I step out into what I think is a
corridor but actually it's the it's the
black cover of a swimming all right
you're on the side on the top and I know
I I just sort of try to walk on water
and then I get wrapped up in the the
cover and now I'm fighting for my life
ended are in the you're in the dark and
you're in the water in pitch black yeah
I don't know what's going on I'm
swimming I'm wearing the watch that my
wife bought me for my anniversary and
I'm trying to keep it out and yet still
live yeah and and I get to the other
side and I get up and I'm shivering and
not with cold but with the certain
knowledge that I have to go back
upstairs to a dinner party how are you
completely soaking you guys I'm drunk I
mean I I'm it's like I've been swimming
yeah yeah I I'm looking I'm looking for
a way out of this as you would and I'm
looking for an open window I'm thinking
maybe I can text my wife and tell her
I've left her and then I don't know
disappear to Mexico that's a good plan
haha and then I see a gleaming row of
white toweling robes and and and towels
so I put on a toning robe and I put my
hair up like I'm Marilyn Monroe and I
press the button and I go back up for
this dinner party and the tea party
opens and I step out I mean literally I
mean I'm dripping a puddle on on the
floor and it was the single worst moment
of my life and I still I still wake up
going oh god no that was a dream no it
wasn't a dream
what did they do when the door opens and
you stand you walk out and suddenly the
penises they pointed and laughed which
is the appropriate I spawned probably it
actually kind of worked out okay because
a plum in those circumstances is
everything yes no well I always think
when something like oh yeah you got to
look as much like you meant to go swing
all the way yeah that's what I would do
I would say I went down there and I'm
the guy with guts who jumped into the
pool in a suit then later on they would
figure out that I'm an idiot yeah that's
the way to go I would just insist that
nothing happened I don't know what
you're talking about
wet who's wet this is how I came to the
party maybe you people on acid it's a
little warm I may be a little dewy but
I'm not wet hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy japanese
pornography